warning there there we go uh and you for
a second you're going to freak out when
you see this clip because for just a
second Alyssa Farah who is the
quote-unquote conservative on the show
but she's a pet conservative they give
her they tap around the head and give
her a cookie at the end and you know
they'll all throw her under the bus and
once she gets fired and I do hope it's
worth the 200 Grand a year for three
years or whatever she's getting on it um
to sell your soul you know you probably
should have negotiated more when you're
selling your soul you get better better
agent but anyway uh she's going to make
sense for a second Alyssa Farah is going
to kind of make sense for a second and
then Sunny Hosten talks so you'll figure
out the rest
quick though two things can be true at
once yesterday was a bad day for Donald
Trump the first indicted former
president I want to see this guy held
accountable this case is not taking
Donald Trump down and I say that for a
couple years how do you know that there
was well just real quick there was no
conspiracy charge which a lot of folks
were looking to see yeah
the felony charges they the max sentence
is four years but this is a first time
offender it's a non-violent crime it's a
classy felony every legal expert I've
talked to has said most likely a fine in
probation if he's even tell you why
you're wrong as a legal expert
I will tell you why you're wrong
prosecutors are not only in the business
of Prosecuting crimes we're in the
business of sending out a message if you
let the president of the United States
be found guilty of one to 34 counts even
if they're misdemeanors and he gets to
go home scot-free you're sending them
that's not free we're just saying it's
going to be a fine information
all right first off just Sonny hoston's
General tone and that's what I'm saying
Alyssa you think they like you now and
you know they don't really like you like
they're just using you but the way that
Sunny Hosten talks
down to people like literally with her
nose up down to people she's so
profoundly unpleasant but okay let that
be what's interesting is she's saying
that you should prosecute to send a
message now that's interesting because
now I would say and I think most people
who believe in equaling under the law
believe that you should be prosecuting
based on the laws that are on the books
so if you I don't know let's say murder
somebody everyone who murders somebody
should be treated equally under the law
and you should have to prove that they
did it they have a chance to prove that
they are not guilty and that's how it
should work but you should prosecute to
send a message it took us literally
point zero zero two seconds to find this
from The New Yorker on Alvin Bragg's
third day as Manhattan district attorney
in January 2021. he stated that his
office would no longer prosecute
low-level offenses such as subway fare
evasion resistance to arrest or
prostitution unless they were part of an
accompanying felony charge so if you
were sending a message if that's what
prosecution is about then this guy has
said to New Yorkers jump the turnstiles
be prostitutes uh resist arrest I mean
the idea that resisting arrest would be
something that wouldn't get you in
trouble is absolutely insane so well I
guess if you're a prostitute and they
are about to arrest you and now you can
not only not get arrested for
prostitution but you can also basically
smack the cop in the face so what was
the message that Alvin Bragg has been
sending to New Yorkers it was break the
law
[Music]
foreign